I'm mark Oppenheimer I'm the director of
the Yale journalism initiative and we're
delighted to sponsor this event along
with the Office of Sustainability of
Yale University Holly Parker and Aaron
Sturges Pascal and I have I was about to
say we've worked hard but we actually
haven't worked terribly hard we were
sufficiently hard to bring together two
people who are remarkable presences in
the debates about parking traffic
sustainability the environment and so
forth
Donald Shoop is going to speak first and
then we're going to go right into Tom
Vanderbilt's presentation and we'd ask
that you reserve all of your comments
and questions for the end and they've
both been incredibly gracious in
suggesting that we allow ample time for
comments and questions at the end as a
preparatory matter let me just say that
we one always wonders when putting
together an event at Yale College what's
the demand for this event and should we
how small a room would it have to be so
that it seems crowded and I'm just
delighted to say that we'd guessed right
and that in fact there is the real
curiosity about the questions that they
ask and about the research that they do
and Donald Shoop who's a graduate of
Yale College and also got his doctorate
in economics here has since taught at
the University of Michigan at Ann Arbor
and also at University of California in
Los Angeles where for some time now he's
been a professor as many of you probably
know he's the author of the high cost of
free parking and perhaps most most
prestigious Lee he has been referred to
by no less an authority than the Wall
Street Journal as a parking rockstar
I think he's the only parking rockstar
in the room anyway and he will be
followed by Tom Vanderbilt who is a
graduate of the University of Wisconsin
and is a longtime freelance journalist
for publications like the New York Times
magazine slate wired and even the late
lamented gourmet he is the author of
traffic which has won him the status of
I believe he's been called a traffic
guru and so with along with the parking
rockstar we have the traffic guru and
between the two of them we think they're
going to prevent present a very exciting
evening of discussion of traffic parking
and our green future so please make sure
that your mobile phones are off or at
least set to some sort of very quiet
setting and please join me in welcoming
first professor Donald Shoop
well thank you for inviting me to speak
to you tonight it's an honor to be here
speaking of the classroom well I can
remember being a student for those of
you who are students or can remember the
days that students I think you may have
figured out that the college professors
come in two types I don't mean the men
and the women or the Liberals and the
Conservatives I mean the dogs and the
cats the dogs run around in packs
they bark a lot and each one tries to
become the top dog but the cats are
solitary they like to mark territory as
as their own so as other cats will stay
out and among professors of
transportation planning the dogs chase
after moving cars or they ride around in
cars with their heads hanging out the
windows excited by speed but cats do not
like riding around in cars so they never
hang their heads out the window cats
instead inspect all of the parked cars
and they mark the tires
they also enjoy sleeping on the hood of
a newly parked car where the engine is
still warm and cars are parked 95% of
the time so well dogs chase after the
cars during the 5 percent of the time
that they're moving I thought I could
learn something about that 95% of the
time that cars are parked so Tom
Vanderbilt and I have divided it up he
gets the five percent of the time the
cars are moving and I get the other
ninety five percent of the time I think
that parking is very important for many
reasons today the group this large said
were you were probably even conceived in
a parked car
I was surprised to learn that I have
been called a parking rockstar which is
of course not a real rock star but I
still aren't thinking of changing my
name to shoot dog well it's also an
honor for something from California
especially Los Angeles to be asked to
talk about transportation planting
another cadet aquiline because here's
the views of most initiatives seem to
have of California and it is true that
we paved a lot over with parking lots
and Easter think that we've even chopped
out all the redwood trees to build gas
stations there are some but I think like
California too much of them of urban
America looks like this picture of
Silicon Valley there's a light rail line
in the lower right hand corner of this
picture but you couldn't call it
transitory as a development and we tend
to ignore this asphalt blight in our
life especially when we're part treated
it as all of these cars are at two
o'clock on a weekday afternoon but
parking is free to us only in our role
as motorists of course just because we
don't pay for parking doesn't mean the
cost ceased to exist we pay for all this
parking dearly and every other aspect of
our life as a homeowner is a employee is
a taxpayer as a citizen no but Silicon
Valley in California are not the only
places where parking dominates the
landscape here's a picture of New Haven
there's a lot of parking in that let me
see I think I have two pictures of New
Haven and see here's one yes where is
this I think you could see the Temple
Street garage in the in the picture of
the connector which was built when I was
a student which really seems to be more
of a divider and here's
another view of the part of the city
there's an awful lot of parking in New
Haven if if more parking for the
solution to urban problems New Haven
would be a very prosperous City there
was a parking garage that was built when
I was a student it's quite a wonderful
piece of sculpture and it works very
well as a garage but I don't think we
should tell ourselves that more parking
is going to solve many of our problems
it was built of course as a part of an
urban renewal project large parts of New
Haven were torn down to provide the
space for this and the shopping center
that I can remember being built has
already been torn down right next to
this parking structure oh so I think we
I'd like to start with some background I
think for both Tom's and my talk is that
our automobiles by themselves consume an
eighth of the world's oil supply every
day and we import 2/3 of this oil for
paying for with borrowed money we have
more vehicles than cars and it doesn't
seem like it when you're a student or a
faculty member at Yale but American
drivers park for you for 99 percent at
the end of all of their trips and I
don't think this is sustainable and the
question is or we'd have a hard landing
or can we figure a way to solve some of
our problems I think we can I think
we've made it two big mistakes as one is
to keep curb parking free or cheap and
to require lots of all street parking
here's the parking requirements in the
city of New Haven which are quite modest
compared to most cities parking
requirements they look very scientific
somebody must know how many parking
spaces a vocational trade or business
school needs or a game room as defined
in Section 42.2 well I think if you
asked any of these patterns where those
numbers could came from
none of them could explain a single one
of these numbers it looks scientific but
it isn't and I think the the the
pretense to knowledge of us planners
that we can tell you how many parking
spaces must be supplied before anything
can be built or any business can be open
it's not a lot of Harlem
that I think it's created great planning
disaster which Peter Hall defines as
something that costs a lot of money is
going seriously wrong
I think that all of this parking excuse
all of our travel choices towards the
car as the natural way to get where you
want to go it's it caused a lot of
sprawl and spreads buildings apart
provide room for the parking between
them a lot of the buildings design is
degraded by having to provide all of the
parking it makes housing more expensive
because it has to include the cost of
the parking this is something that even
many planners don't understand it makes
it very different or difficult to reuse
older buildings because if you want to
open up restaurant in a former shoe
store the planners will say well where
is the required partner and if you don't
have the required partner you can't open
the restaurant so older buildings can't
fulfill the role that they could in the
city limits homeownership is very
difficult to do to convert apartment
buildings where people rent into
condominiums that they can own it
damages the urban economy I think it's
done that in New Haven have you don't
have to explain the fact that it harms
the environment so some cities are
solving this problem in a new way is to
get the price of parking right here's
some of the reforms that are going on
this charge the right price for curb
parking by that I mean the lowest price
you can charge and have one or two
vacant spaces on every block that's
about 85% occupancy rate so the parking
is well used it's almost full but it's
readily available anybody driving down
any Street in your city can
we see one or two open spaces ready to
park in front of any store or restaurant
so that you can go with and the cities
have made this politically popular by
returning the meter revenue to the
neighborhood's that generate it if you
put in parking meters and charge per
these performance prizes for parking
you'll get the revenue and that has
tended to make it very popular with the
merchants and the landowners and the
residents who benefit from the added
public services in their neighborhoods
and once you do that you could remove or
produce at least the minimum parking
requirements because you won't have to
see you nobody can say there's not
enough parking because wherever you go
you'll see plenty of parking and I think
this freedom from parking requirements
will mean you could use any building for
any business that's legal now here's an
example of what they're doing in San
Francisco they're starting this policy
and this is just an example of the
prices that they expect to charge you'll
the prices will be the lowest price they
can charge at any hour and still have
one or two vacant spaces on every block
so it'll be different at different times
of day it'd be different on different
parts of the city it can be higher at
the second hour it's once you say that
we have a principle that we understand
this is the price that we want the price
that will lead to convenient parking and
well used parking that's how we're going
to set the price we're not going to let
just inertia set prices and because they
have a twenty million dollar grant from
the federal government to institute this
they have lots of money for graphic
artists and and important for anything
you want to do that here is an example
of what they say is what's wrong with
the city is that some locks have all the
spaces occupied and other blocks have
some vacancies so the idea is you raise
the price on the top block and you lower
it on the bottom block you get something
like this it's that simple
some people think that this charge of
use market prices for parking or
with social upheaval compared like the
Reformation or prohibition so some
enormous change of the way we do live
our lives but look what a small change
can achieve what is a good result so
it's very easy to legislate this here's
the exact it's ordinance language in one
city and Northern California is that the
City Council ceased trying to set the
price for every parking space and
micromanagement it should be a dollar an
hour with a limit of two hours they said
they did put a policy Bobby should do as
they set the policy of what they want
the parking supply to do to be readily
available but well used and they say
they establish it they give the
transportation authority of the the the
responsibility to move to move the price
up and down the council members can just
look out the window and see if they've
done their job if they if the spaces are
half empty the price is too high
the space is wrongful the price is too
low and they made this popular by
returning the money to the metered zone
so that all the affected parties the
stakeholders as we call them now
supported it it passed the City Council
unanimously they also removed the time
limits on curb parking because if the
prices are going to set the the create
vacancies you don't need to force
turnover you shouldn't have a low price
and force people out of spaces at the
end of 24 minutes or 30 minutes or an
hour you should let people park as long
as they're willing to pay because the
curb parking is more expensive than the
off street parking anybody who wants to
park for a long time naturally
gravitates to the off street parking
those as simple as the Goldilocks
principle of parking prices we all learn
this as the children you know a bed
shouldn't be too soft or too firm but
parking prices shouldn't be too high or
too low and I think one of the problems
with our existing system of having low
prices
is that it creates cruising for girl
parking which is driving around the
block we've all done it many times
hunting for a parking space that here's
a situation you could face almost any
city the curb park is cheaper than all
street parking how long would you be
willing to drive around hunting for a
curb space rather than pay to park off
street we all face this problem and
because of this problem there's an awful
lot of curb cruising for curb parking
and here's a survey sort of summary of
surveys first one was in 1927
appropriately in Detroit
finding the seven twenty to thirty fifth
to a third of all the cars on the street
for cruising for her parking the most
recent ones were in New York was a very
clever a technique of interviewing
drivers who were stopped at the traffic
lights and asked them if they were
hunting for her parking and you can see
that here on one spot twenty-eight
percent no though there was forty five
percent of the cars were cruising for
party that is an environmental and a
transportation crime just think it's a
wasted fuel the air pollution creating
congestion and this is sort of what it
looks like this was a study done in
Chicago in 1939 where they stationed I'm
sure they were undergraduates at a lot
of corners and they they they noted
every car that passed every intersection
I wrote down with license plate in the
exact time so they could recreate the
path of travel of every car
some people were obsessed with parking
around one block and something were open
to new experiences but try something
different and this leads to a lot of
very risky behavior people will they're
only focused on trying to get a parking
space they they they ignore my cyclists
they ignore pedestrians and you see I've
seen it happen if car sees across a
vacancy on the other side of the street
they'll make a u-turn in the middle of
the street which is very dangerous
here's some grainy footage I got and
research yeah
I I was able to interview the driver
afterwards and she says she knows that
it's cheaper to park as a urban she does
whatever it takes to get a curb parking
space well here is the results that we
found in Westwood Village but we studied
this for a year in this little 15-block
area there are almost a million miles of
vehicle travel humming for underpriced
car park that is after you get through
this little 15-block area there are a
million miles a year of traffic hunting
for underpriced curb parking
though that we found that on average
there were two cars circling every block
and hood only three and a three minutes
to find the space but there's so many
people who park in a year that it all
adds up that's equal to four trips to
the moon in a 15-block area is happening
all over the earth all over the earth
you know some people will say it's
unamerican to charge curb parking even
if it does if it is would help the
environment but I think it's very
American to charge people for what they
use there's a picture of homeowners in
around the LA Coliseum during the
Olympics in 1984 and it happens during
every event of the Coliseum the
residents parked their own cars on the
street and rent out their driveways to
ticket holders some people think is too
difficult to do what I'm saying because
they have the idea that all parking
meters are like the original parking
meter in 1935 is that you put your money
in the slot you turn the lever and that
you hope to get back before your time
runs out that when they were invented
they were condemned as being a devilish
combination of alarm clock and a slot
machine
you take your risk but that's because
most Americans
no of all the progress has happened
everywhere else on earth we're now the
lagging behind the rest of the earth of
meter technology here's the parking
meters of the sort that some cities have
put in maybe New Haven has them but this
is all the UCLA campus designed to look
like a retro parking meter
but dusty visa accept coins accept only
credit cards and dollar bills it doesn't
tell you what the price is until you
push a button any button and then it
tells you what the price is at that time
and here it is it doesn't mean tell with
the price per hours but of course it's
three dollars for the first hour of the
four dollars for the second hour well
let's see is this too high it's just
asking too much for college students to
pay well I say you can't tell whether
the price is right until you look at the
results so I think some of you were
aware the professors have a lot of spare
time and I set up my camera across from
the the the meter and looked at eight
parking spaces controlled by this meter
you can see it there is the meter and
there was somebody pay and I think that
one out of eight spaces should be vacant
around that let's look what happened
during the hour we see the shadows move
as the time goes by some people leave
some people go sometimes there were all
the spaces were full but they were
quickly vacancy sometimes two vacancies
once three vacancies then they filled up
so this is what happens at the end of
the hour and I think that this shows to
me that that was the bright price in
that location at that time and I don't
see how anybody go are you saying is too
high or it's too low what principle
would you use to say that price was
wrong it could be it would be different
at a different time but that's what I'm
arguing for now I think that it's easy
enough to do that we have a choice our
first future is just to change nothing
that I think inertia is the major driver
of
curb parking policies and curb parking
prices in the United States
keep curb parking free or cheap and
brick are ample off street parking and
will live in this world with us of this
appalling and where people are told to
buy a cheap car your low-income people
are told to buy a cheap car rather than
right in the bus will bite lots of cars
and big cars and park them for free
here's in front of the Kodak Theater on
Hollywood Boulevard
we'll need lots of roads for these cars
here's a New Brunswick Maryland we'll
need lots of freeways and we'll have
plenty of congestion with people on
their way to their parked car just to
their free parking but we do have a
possibility for a second future which i
think is far better as the jersey's
performance-based prices for curb
parking we could use the revenue to fix
it to prepare sidewalks to play the
street trees to put wires underground to
improve neighborhoods to pay for public
infrastructure and then we could remove
all street parking requirements so
here's the kind of world that some
people say this is what he's
recommending but let me conclude by
where I began in Silicon Valley suppose
you bought into this policy and I'm
certainly I'm kind of an evangelist as
you could tell that I'm trying to
convince people that we're doing the
wrong thing and we should do the right
thing suppose they bought my ideas as a
remove the parking requirements on this
land which is now committed to parking
you couldn't build it in El Sona because
it wouldn't have the required form they
were that that building is as big as it
can be given that parking lot suppose
you said we've removed the parking
requirements and allowed them to build
on this law now I pick buildings from
the University of London because they
look nice I was speaking to the Congress
for new urbanism and they liked these
buildings and they must have just been
cleaned but we wouldn't get that in
California so I just took a more
pedestrian
apartment buildings in Los Angeles said
suppose you tried it and remember
everybody in Silicon Valley complains
that the traffic congestion is terrible
the cost of housing is so high that
commutes are so long that this would
address all of those problems that
remember all of those cars or many of
those cars and that lot are imported in
California you cannot import apartment
houses so if you were an electrician or
a plumber or drywall builder or roofer
you'd probably think this was a great
idea if you were worker at Cisco Systems
you could walk across the parking lot
to get to work if that worked out if
they made much more money by using that
land for housing rather than for their
employees job adjacent housing then for
free parking they could just keep on
doing it and it could quickly become to
look like a city as you walked along
that sidewalk the curb park it wouldn't
be free but there would be street trees
and there would be building is it going
to have ground-floor retail what would
we do with all the parking garages that
we won't need all the temple street
garages and what the air rights garage
says but here's one of the holida they
found a wonderful new use for it I think
the Yale students could do this too
but I think that that these reforms are
needed unless General Motors succeeds
with this ace-in-the-hole has really got
a great idea and if it if it if it
succeeds I think everybody yeah we'll
buy one of these cars here's the I think
that would be great for Yale students
and faculty of staff well I think
planters should always get lewd with the
quote from Jane Jacobs that we aren't
rich because of what we have done we are
a prosperous nation because of what
we've inherited and it's up to us to
make it to continue this prosperity and
I think our current parking policies are
driving us in the wrong direction and I
think that we have a president who likes
to pull Abraham Lincoln there's nobody
better the court in the United States
history I think our case is new and I
think that maybe ten years ago it would
have been unthinkable to recommend
market prices for curb parking planners
rejected markets as sort of an alien
ideology but I think now we're more
willing to look at prices of the way to
solve our problems so that's about all I
know is why I better stop thank you very
much